.
REPUBLICAN LEADERS FOR THEIR
PART SAY THE BIDEN PLAN IS TOO
EXPENSIVE.
>> DEMOCRATIC SENATOR ELIZABETH
WARREN IS FIRED UP ABOUT ANOTHER
PROPOSAL IN PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
ADDRESS TO CONGRESS.
>> AMERICAN FAMILIES PLAN WILL
PROVIDE ACCESS TO QUALITY
AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND GUARANTEE --
>> AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE IS AN
URGENT ISSUE FOR MANY WORKING
MOTHERS.
IN 34 STATES AND WASHINGTON,
D.C., THE COST OF CHILDCARE IS
MORE THAN THE COST OF IN-STATE
COLLEGE TUITION.
IN HER NEW BOOK "PERSIST,"
SENATOR WARREN TALKS ABOUT HER
PLANS FOR CHILDCARE, STUDENT
DEBT, AND OTHER ISSUES.
SHE ALSO LOOKS BACK AT THE 2020
PRESIDENTIAL RACE AND WHY HER
CAMPAIGN FELL SHORT.
SENATOR WARREN JOINS US NOW FROM
BOSTON.
SENATOR, GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
>> GOOD MORNING.
I'M DELIGHTED TO BE HERE WITH
YOU.
>> LET ME START WITH WHAT WE
WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT -- THAT
THE PRESIDENT PLANS TO MEET WITH
REPUBLICANS THIS WEEK TO TRY TO
FIND SOME COMMON GROUND ON
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IS THERE COMMON GROUND TO BE
FOUND, DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, LET ME SET THE TABLE
FOR YOU JUST A LITTLE BIT ON
THIS.
REMEMBER WHAT'S HAPPENED TO US?
JUST THE PAST YEAR.
WE'VE GONE THROUGH A WORLDWIDE
PANDEMIC, WE'VE HAD A RACIAL
RECK
RECKONING, AN ARMED
INSURRECTION.
WE NOW HAVE A NEW PRESIDENT, AND
WE HAVE PASSED AN HISTORIC
RESCUE PACKAGE.
WE HAVE OUR TOES SET ON WHAT
HAPPENS TO CHANGE AMERICA.
WHAT KIND OF AMERICA WE WANT TO
BUILD GOING FORWARD.
AND -- AND SO OFTEN IN
WASHINGTON THE DOORS TO CHANGE
ARE JUST LOCKED TIGHT.
BUT RIGHT NOW, THEY'RE OPEN,
THEY'RE OPEN JUST A CRACK, BUT
PEOPLE ACROSS THIS COUNTRY WANT
TO SEE US MAKE CHANGE.
THEY WANT TO SEE A GOVERNMENT
THAT IS INVESTING IN OPPORTUNITY
FOR EVERYBODY, AND PART OF THAT
IS BUILDING AN INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT REALLY LETS PEOPLE GET TO
WORK AND PRODUCE AND KEEP THIS
ECONOMY ON A POSITIVE NOTE.
THAT'S -- THAT'S WHAT MY BOOK IS
ABOUT BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT THE
NEXT 100 DAYS.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
>> BUT SENATOR --
>> REPUBLICANS, DEMOCRATS, WE
AL NEED TO BE IN THIS FIGHT.
>> BUT SENATOR, REPUBLICANS SAY
THAT THE PRICE OF THIS BILL IS
WAY TOO HIGH, THE DIFFERENCE ON
THE TWO PROPOSALS IS MILES
APART.
CAN YOU MEET SOMEWHERE IN THE
MIDDLE THERE, AND IF NOT, ARE
YOU PREPARED TO GO TO THE BUDGET
-- AGAIN?
>> LOOK, I AM PREPARED TO GO TO
BUDGET RECONCILIATION.
I'M SOMEBODY WHO THINKS THAT THE
FILIBUSTER SHOULD NOT BE USED TO
GIVE REPUBLICANS A VETO ON
THINGS THAT THIS COUNTRY NEEDS.
BUT KEEP IN MIND THE THINGS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ROADS AND
BRIDGES.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CHILDCARE.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ACROSS
THIS NATION NEED ROADS AND
BRIDGES.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ACROSS
THIS NATION NEED CHILDCARE.
THERE IS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR
THE CHANGES THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE.
AND THE IDEA THAT THERE ARE
FOLKS IN WASHINGTON WHO DON'T
WANT TO DO IT, THAT JUST MEANS
THE REST OF US NEED TO GET OUT
THERE AND GET IN THE FIGHT AND
PUSH OUR ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES
IN WASHINGTON SO THAT WE MAKE
THE INVESTMENTS IN THIS COUNTRY
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE GOING
FORWARD.
>> SENATOR WARREN, YOU'RE RIGHT,
THERE IS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OUT
THERE IN THE COUNTRY FOR A LOT
OF THE THINGS IN THE DEMOCRATS'
BILL.
AND YET IN WASHINGTON, THERE'S
NOT.
AND THE ARGUMENT AGAINST IT,
FROM WASHINGTON, IS IT'S GOING
TO ADD TOO MUCH TO THE NATIONAL
DEBT.
IT'S GOING TO SOMEHOW BANKRUPT
THE NEXT GENERATION.
WE SHOULD RUN THE COUNTRY LIKE A
HOUSEHOLD.
YO KNOW THIS STUFF BETTER THAN
MOST SENATORS.
SO SIMPLE QUESTION -- DOES THE
DEFICIT REALLY MATTER THESE
DAYS?
>> SO LOOK, WHY IS IT THAT
REPUBLICANS TALK ABOUT THE
DEFICIT ONLY WHEN DEMOCRATS ARE
TALKING ABOUT LET'S INVEST IN
CHILDCARE AND CANCELING STUDENT
LOANS AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY.
EITHER YOU HAVE A MATTER OF
PRINCIPLE THAT YOU THINK IT'S
ALWAYS A PROBLEM, OR YOU DON'T.
MY VIEW RIGHT NOW IS WE ARE
COMING OUT OF A REALLY SERIOUS
ECONOMIC HOLE.
IT'S GOOD, FRANKLY, FOR US TO BE
SPENDING, TO BE PUTTING MONEY
INTO PEOPLE'S POCKETS, AND TO BE
BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT I DO WANT TO SAY THERE ARE A
LOT OF WAYS WE CAN BE RAISING
REVENUE, AND WE SHOULD BE
RAISING REVENUE.
WE SHOULD HAVE A WEALTH TAX.
WE SHOULD HAVE A TAX ON REAL
CORPORATE PROFITS.
AND WE SHOULD ENFORCE THE
CURRENT TAX LAWS ON THE BOOKS.
IF WE DID THOSE THREE THINGS,
WE'D HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO PAY
FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, HIS FAMILY
CAREGIVING BILL, AND STILL HAVE
A COUPLE OF TRILLION DOLLARS
LEFT OVER.
>> IN YOUR BOOK, "PERSISTS,"
SENATOR, YOU GET PERSONAL, VERY
CANDID IN WAYS THAT WE HAVEN'T
SEEN BEFORE.
YOU EVEN TELL THE STORY AS
CLICHE AS IT IS, AS A YOUNG LAW
STUDENT, A PROFESSOR LITERALLY
CHASING YOU AROUND THE DESK.
YOU'RE SITTING IN THE
ORTHODONTIST'S OFFICE GETTING
YOUR TEETH WORKED ON AFTER
SOMEBODY SAID, WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO ABOUT HER MOUTH, BUT
YOU'RE SITTING THERE, AND THE
GUY -- THE DENTIST ASKED YOU, AS
YOU'RE READING THE LAW BOOK, IS
YOUR HUSBAND A LAWYER?
YOU GO, NO, IS YOUR WIFE AN
ORTHODONTIST?
WHICH I THOUGHT WAS VERY FUNNY,
BY THE WAY.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS VERY FUNNY.
YOU SAID IN 2020 YOU -- YOU HAD
TO GET -- HOW DID YOU PHRASE IT,
2020 LOSING WAS NEW FOR YOU.
AND IT WAS VERY PAINFUL, AND IT
HURT, AND IT STUNG.
SO HOW DID YOU GET THROUGH THAT?
HOW DID YOU PROCESS THAT?
YOU TELL A GREAT CONVERSATION OF
YOU AND YOUR HUSBAND SITTING ON
THE COUCH WHERE HE SAYS, I THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO PULL THIS OFF.
THIS HURT DEEPLY.
HOW DID YOU GET THROUGH IT?
>> YOU KNOW, I DID WHAT MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
HAVE DONE, PARTICULARLY OVER THE
LAST YEAR.
AND THAT IS YOU TAKE THAT MOMENT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT YOURSELF AND
SAY WHY AM I IN THIS FIGHT, WHY
DO I DO THIS, WHY DO I GET UP IN
THE MORNING, WHAT KEEPS ME UP
LATE AT NIGHT.
AND FOR ME, IT'S ABOUT THE
FIGHTS THAT DREW ME INTO THE
PRESIDENTIAL RACE.
I CARE ABOUT CHILDCARE.
I CARE ABOUT CANCELING STUDENT
LOANS.
AND SO IT WASN'T SO MUCH ABOUT,
WELL, I LOST SO I'M THROUGH.
NO.
IT'S I LOST SO I NEED TO FIND
OTHER WAYS TO CONTINUE THIS
FIGHT BECAUSE THE NEED FOR
CHILDCARE IS AS GREAT AS EVER.
THE NEED FOR WEALTH TAXES IS
GREAT AS EVER.
THE NEED TO CANCEL STUDENT LOAN
DEBT IS AS GREAT AS EVER.
SO THE BOOK IS ABOUT VERY
PERSONAL STORIES, IT'S ABOUT THE
STORIES OF PEOPLE I LOVE.
BUT THAT'S WHAT KEEPS ME IN THIS
FIGHT EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> YOU ALSO -- IT WAS A VOTER, A
SUPPORTER WHO REALLY SORT OF
GAVE YOU THE IMPETUS, IT SEEMED,
FOR YOU TO KEEP GOING.
YOU OPENED THE DOOR, YOU WALK
OUT, AND THERE ON YOUR SIDEWALK
IS WHAT?
I LOVE THIS.
YEAH.
>> SO PEOPLE HAD TAKEN CHALK AND
STARTED WRITING ON THE SIDEWALK
OUTSIDE OUR HOUSE.
AND THE MORNING AFTER I DROPPED
OUT OF THE RACE, I OPENED THE
DOOR, AND THERE IN TWO-FOOT-HIGH
LETTERS, I AM NOT GOING TO MISS
THIS, HEAVILY CHALKED IN IS THE
WORD "PERSIST."
AND IT WAS LIKE A BUCKET OF COLD
WATER IN THE FACE.
AND I THOUGHT, THAT'S RIGHT.
I KNOW WHY I GOT IN THE FIGHT,
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT, AND YOU
KNOW WHAT, I'M STILL IN THAT
FIGHT.
I PERSIST.
>> YOU ARE STILL FIGHTING, YOU
ARE STILL PERSISTING MUCH THE
BOOK, PEOPLE YOU TALK ABOUT
SEXISM IN YOUR OWN CAREER, IN
YOUR OWN LIFE.
IT'S A VERY INTERESTING READ.
WE THANK YOU, SENATOR WARREN,
FOR YOUR TIME.
GAVE PEOPLE A LOT T